who are some of the guys that you saw on
your watch that weren't just driven by
the money where there's some names that
you looked at and says these three guys
or as crazy as I am I do at the time I
deal with what I've referred to as goat
mountain I went to goat mountain and I
talked to magic Michael Bird Hakeem
Olajuwon Jerry West Oscar Robinson Bill
Russell you know so I would talk to them
what did you do what were your
experiences Michael in particular he's
become my big brother it's been my big
brother since I first came in the league
and what was that process like so I went
to them I started understanding the ins
and outs of the game and you know how
they approach things and their level of
detail and obsessiveness and that's what
I did why do you think and first let me
ask how it felt but I'm curious to know
why you think as well how do you feel
knowing like from the moment you got
into the league the guy at the time he's
the greatest of all time everybody wants
to be like my Gatorade all this stuff
the level of respect he had for you when
he spoke about you was different than
everybody else and you're Nadine 19 year
old kid at that time yeah how did that
feel when you heard how we spoke about
you yeah it made me feel good but like
what I told him I was like you didn't
say anything I didn't already know so
you know so like wait I tell you like
when we when I was in high school and I
used to work out with the 76ers I used
to ask him you know what's it like the
guard Mike you know Mike mean black
Jesus Mike what though
black hoof but we call him black Jesus
or you can call him black cat I'm gonna
call him [ __ ] Mike yes his [ __ ]
name so the level of fear that he
inspired in others was insane and I
would tell him I said when I face him
we're gonna go at it this is odd you
don't want to do that I'm like what man
you don't know me man so when we matched
up I think he understood that and you
know when I was 18 my first year he got
the best of me a bunch of times I was
right there the next play
you're not intimidating me I'm not going
anywhere and I think you saw that level
of respect I think he was the same way
at 18 years old and that common bond is
what I think you know where our
connection was built yeah it was great
watching you guys going back and forth
whether it was the all-star game or
whether the famous scene where you know
you're guarding him he's in front of
you're asking him a question there's a
question and he same footwork and do
this yeah it's just beautiful watching
that take place with the two of you guys
how's your relationship today that was
my big brother man like I can't you know
it's uh we talk often you send each
other's Christmas cards every year and
each other Christmas kever year that we
have nothing to do with but yet still
you know but we're extremely close man
extremely extremely close that's dream
that's great - yeah you know it's a as a
fan I'm not in your world your world is
a whole different world I just see it
from a fan and I just see it from what
experts say but as a fan I feel that's
exactly how would be with you and him
because the level of respect from both
is reciprocal and it's great to hear
that
[Music]